toujours de bonne humeur
on
et les hyperactifs et exigeant
je m'appelle un livre aussi
j'ai 29 ans je suis né à marseille ça
fait quinze ans que j'habite à la
réunion du coup mon coeur est là et je
fabrique du savon artisanal reçu
l'essentiel et aux huiles végétales et
avec un maximum de
d'épicés fleurs et produits pays
pour dénicher moi je vous montrerai
comment on fait des savoirs
moi ce qui me plaît dans ce métier c'est
ce côté là créatif oh
c'est ça enfin en fait on peut toujours
du nouveau toujours toujours donc ça
c'est les bienfaits de manse avancé que
les 100 % nature il est fait qu'avec des
ivg talent d argile du thé du miel sur
l'abeille moins que nature
des produits qui pour moi sont sains qui
a aussi bien pour moi que pour
l'environnement donc ça c'est hyper
important et puis la deuxième des choses
c'est parce que ça fait marcher à un
commerce local avec quelqu'un qui fait
une activité qui utilisent des produits
est également dit fier donc je soutient
énormément de ça c'est naturel et que tu
as là dessus ben moi je suis sur un
nuage j'ai bien
c'est bio ça sent bon oui très bon
sens
salut
ça va savoir oui
c'est quelqu'un de très simple
sympathique
passionné par ce qu'il fait
à essayer de découvrir d'autres notre
essai sans ces deux idées oui pensez
savon et l' aime ce qu'il fait c'est un
artisan qui
qui travaille pour la réunion vézian